investigation underway following a
police shooting in a mobile home park
happened last night near pecos and lake
mead metro says neighbors called about a
man who was walking around with a gun
after initially running away from
officers they say that man raised his
gun at them that's when officers opened
fire the man now in custody recovering
from minor injuries no officers were
hurt
last year you'll remember donald hartl
told 8 news now someone took his late
wife's name and voted for her in the
last election
yesterday he pleaded guilty and admitted
he was actually the one who voted twice
a judge sentenced donald kirk hardl to
probation and has to pay a fine as part
of a plea deal he agreed to plead guilty
to just one charge of voting more than
once in the same election
hartle said in court he regretted his
actions the judge said this
ultimately this seems to be to me
a cheap political stunt that kind of
backfired
and showed that our voting system
actually works works because you were
ultimately caught
republicans used heartless case last
year as a sign in indication of the
fraud that they had claimed was taking
place if hartle stays out of trouble his
charge will be reduced to a misdemeanor
and again will pay a two thousand dollar
fine
investigators in nevada say there is no
evidence of widespread voter fraud
across the state
well changes are being considered to an
area popular among hikers and climbers
calico basin sits just outside the red
rock scenic loop a new proposal from the
bureau of land management shows that the
possibility of adding a gate and a fee
booth to the entrance there a report
from the blm says it could help manage
the number of people who visit while
preserving nature there's a virtual
public meeting planned for thursday that
meeting is from 6 to 8 p.m on the blm
website comments will be accepted
through december 8th it is a very
popular area john there's some neat
houses back in there too beautiful back
there all right it's 605. so the
holidays are right around the corner
quite literally next week is
thanksgiving but unfortunately so are
those packaged themes oh yeah it's like
they're gearing up already this new
study expecting crimes to surge this
holiday season so hector mejia is going
to break down some reminders for those
of us maybe who haven't had this problem
yet it could happen so hector what do we
need to know
yeah it really could you know heather
i've had flowers and also deodorant
still and right from my doorstep and
we've learned packaged thieves are added
early this year with a record number of
early online holiday sales these
precious packages are arriving at
doorsteps a lot sooner this year and
there are some ways to protect yourself
so we've learned about a study by cctv
camera world ranking nevada as number 22
where you're least likely to have a
package stolen and they warn everyone
should stay on alert every single day of
the year so the study points to a report
revealing that 43 percent of those
surveyed all across the country last
year have had a package stolen at least
once and almost two-thirds said they've
been a victim more than once so here are
some ways to prevent these thefts you
can sign up for tracking and text alerts
this feature will let you know as soon
as an item gets delivered you can invest
in a porch lock box those are designed
with a code that you give to the
delivery service and they lock up your
item you can also have your packages
shipped to work or to an amazon locker
or even choose the in-store pickup you
can also ask for a simple packaging that
doesn't really tell people what you're
getting delivered another thing to keep
in mind these uh package thefts happen
all year long not just during the
holiday season reporting live hector
mejia live local now some thief out
there smelling like hector i know yeah
it's one thing to have your flowers
stolen that's horrible but when your
deodorant gets taken that is
excessive that is a felony that is
unacceptable offensive really hector
thank you very much
the more you know
all right so
thanksgiving is next thursday have you
started shopping for the big meal
many of you have because the store
shelves are already empty in some places
but if you haven't you may actually want
to get started today the prices are
rising bianca holman joining us live in
8 news now kitchen with where you can
find those good deals bianca
hey good morning john good morning
heather so hopefully you have stocked up
your fridge and you're ready to roast
that turkey because things are flying
off the shelves at the supermarket so we
of course looked up some deals for you
and we actually looked up at this
website it is called pennypinchers.com
and they share some great savings that
you might want to take advantage of to
save some coins so the goal is to snag
your coupons and find the deals early
but this year the nation's supply chain
crunch is making some items harder to
find and one thing you may have already
noticed turkeys the u.s department of
agriculture says inventory is down 24
percent this year
on the website penny pinchers they list
target as having butterball turkeys for
99 cents per pound but stores like
walmart are charging a dollar 48 uh per
pound also albertsons and sprouts
they're charging almost two bucks per
pound uh for those turkeys and of course
on our website uh on social media and
twitter we have reached out and saying
hey what do you plan on doing have you
bought your turkeys already so there's a
couple of people that posted they said
they may have gotten theirs from
albertsons and then also there's some
people who want to do prepared meals
they don't plan on getting in the
kitchen and banging pots and pans around
they said they're doing lucille's
barbecue
for thanksgiving dinner so coming up in
the next half hour we're going to talk
about more tips and ways that you can
save this holiday season back to you
guys next time
the barbecue yeah buy it all there's so
many good places to do that here in las
vegas no reason to stress out about it
bianca thank you very much
the animal foundation is looking for
families to foster pets this holiday
season well this is such a fun thing and
here's the deal they're not only going
to send you home with this pet they're
going to send you home with everything
you need and if you decide to adopt the
pet before the end of the year you don't
have to pay a fee you can apply to be a
foster on the animal foundation's
website if nothing else you get a dog a
protective loud dog and they'll keep
your deodorant from getting stolen from
your porch exactly yeah they'll just
bark those leaves away we need to get
hector dog coming up on good day las
vegas a bit of a setback for the vegas
golden knights
two star players who are now on the
nhl's covet list but first let's check
in with sherry swins and look outside on
a beautiful wednesday morning sherry
good morning to you good morning you
guys well it is gorgeous out there as we
take a look at your day planner we will
have clouds moving in and out of our
skies through the day but temperatures
are going to take a little bit of a
slide so today we're talking about 71
degrees for the afternoon high but going
forward temperatures look cooler as we
head towards your thanksgiving holiday
yes it looks like jacket sweater weather
may be right around the corner we've
been spoiled for a long long time your
most accurate forecast is coming up
right after the break
sponsored by the southern nevada water
authority
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now 6 15
good morning everybody uh it was a tough
test for the vegas golden nights last
night that's right so they welcomed the
carolina hurricanes to t-mobile arena
hurricanes boasting the second best
record in the nhl a very very good team
so the golden knights fell behind in the
first period but then they came storming
back in the second brett hauden you saw
them there him there making a nice
little move shay theodore also scoring
they scored goals just 80 seconds apart
but in the third period carolina poured
in two more goals to earn a 4-2 win
i think
i come to expect that we're not going to
quit
i think i'm more disappointed
2-2 going into the third chance to get
points and
we don't do that you know i thought
you have to give credit to them very
good team and they really put a lot of
pressure on you don't give you a lot
yeah carolina stanley cup contender they
are very very good the golden knights
are back in action tomorrow night at the
fortress hosting the detroit red wings
puck drops at seven and then columbus
comes to town saturday night but vegas
is missing will carrier and jonathan
marsh or so a star player both on the
nhl's covid protocol list right now so
more setbacks for the golden knights all
right well come back voting is underway
for the nfl pro bowl the all-star event
is coming to allegiant stadium in las
vegas in february fans can buy tickets
now at probowl.com prices start at 100
with fees tickets are also include
access to the pro bowl red carpet and
some other family friendly fun things to
do
that week so lots of fun festivities big
deal to get the all-star game the pro
bowl right it's basically it's kind of
like the also ran of all all-star games
though for pro sports
in hawaii for years and the nhl all-star
game is going to be here too absolutely
hey we're switching to baseball now
though big league weekend coming back to
las vegas of course they skipped the
annual game a year ago because of the
pandemic the cleveland guardians
formerly known as the indians they'll be
taking on the oakland athletics mark
your calendars march 12th and 13th
against the las vegas ballpark you can
get tickets to the aviator's box office
and we were talking about this is this a
a hint you know because the oakland
athletics have been making a lot of
noise about possibly relocating to las
vegas and they are the parent team
of the aviators
well who's played here before usually
the cubs play yeah for years and years
and years so who else usually comes in
trying to see if the dodgers have
because that's what i really care about
i don't believe that if the dodgers have
done a big league weekend it would have
been a long time ago yeah yeah you
shouldn't be hiding anything yep seems
like the a's have been here before for
big league weekend but maybe not they've
actually played a regular season game at
cashman field back when there are some
stadium issues at the oakland coliseum
which is hard to imagine yeah i don't
figure right
i wonder if that's why they keep coming
here
we'll take them they can come please
yeah we're talking about all the all the
football games don't we have the east
west shrine collegiate game in february
2. there's a lot of colleges i think
that's happening at allegiant in
february so we got a lot of good
football we're at sports town there's
some college hoops this weekend some big
time college troops unlv is playing like
michigan or amazon
and they're doing good yes three and a
half yeah
this has been your sports roundup
let's talk weather though yeah let's get
your weather round up yeah what's coming
it is gorgeous isn't that pretty another
nice sunrise out there and uh yes
yesterday skies were covered top to
bottom with clouds and it was just like
red too at this hour of the morning
didn't last long but i always say you
know if we have beautiful sunrises
sunsets whatever weather events are
going on send us some pictures share
your pics with us at eight
pix pix eight news now dot com brenda
tinnell did that this was yesterday
morning skye she had she captured a
really beautiful colors so we had almost
the the red and then the pinks and the
blues and then it kind of faded out but
she was able to get a great couple of
shots in before we lost the color so
thank you brenda really appreciate you
sharing your great photos with us we've
got a lot of 50s around town a couple of
spots are cooling off to the 40s of
seven hills red rocks in the mid 40s low
40s up at kyle canyon northwest of the
valley now tule springs we've had some
northerly breezes that have been up 15
to 20 miles an hour and we're already
starting to feel those northerly winds
picking up along the river laughlin to
bullhead city
breezy this morning but looking for
winds could get up to 35 miles an hour
this afternoon so pressure gradient
tightening a little bit and that sends
some stronger winds along the river we
will look for temperatures to be
slightly cooler today and we're down to
the 40s in prompt indian springs low 50s
in mesquite 54 in boulder city right now
freezing up in caliani look at 28 in
cedar city it's a little chilly there 21
in ely over into kingman don't want to
forget about you kingman at 39 and we've
got 30s in tonopah as well as reno this
morning so colder air has been invading
the northwest and the intermountain west
into the rockies look at these 20s this
morning denver's had a few snow showers
right around and there's a wildfire a
fire up there around estes park
northwest of denver they got a little
bit of snow so that's good they need
that moisture but in the southwest we're
doing okay we've got 50s and near 60
degrees areas like phoenix la and a lot
of warmer air that's being pushed out
ahead of a cold front in the middle of
the country boy it's got 60s all the way
up to cincinnati and chicago this
morning even cleveland's in the upper
50s they're slightly warmer than we are
this morning but once that cold front
passes through those temperatures are
going to change for sure so we've got
this front that's just kind of
meandering around southern nevada and so
that will keep things a little on the
cooler side and behind it once it goes
through then that will reinforce the
cooler temperatures really for the rest
of the week high clouds high thin cirrus
clouds will stay dry those will keep
passing through at times we'll look for
71 today that's about 5 degrees cooler
than yesterday's 76 you only had that
full-on sunshine for the afternoon it
was gorgeous yesterday mostly sunny
again tomorrow but temps down another
couple of degrees and look at those
mornings in the 40s so jackets and maybe
an extra blanket on the bed get those
heater filters changed we've got more
clouds friday saturday and cooler 60s
coming next week right before
thanksgiving all right let's jump on the
roads check the drive here's nate yeah
trying to get you out the door safely
before 6 30 and normally this is the
time when things start to get a little
bit funky
actually it's improving the last hour we
had a couple of crashes one of them more
recently on the southbound side of the
95 515 around boulder highway you do see
the slowing further ahead for the
northbound right so this crash has
cleared again it was generally in the
opposite direction but man it was kind
of like a parking lot on the southbound
side i still got some folks with their
headlights on which is always a good
idea that is the generally bigger flow
of traffic but for now the big slowdown
does and continue to be the big squeeze
down to those two lanes and a little bit
of sewing now on the 95 on the other
side from the spaghetti bowl over
towards the rainbow curve but no crashes
to report on the freeways we'll be
keeping an eye on it for you also coming
up we have some viewers chiming in on
that what's driving you crazy email
about giant video screens next to busy
roads that's next on good day las vegas
live local now
[Music]
6 24 wednesday morning i've got some
viewers chiming in on that
email about giant video screens next to
busy roads remember the other day viewer
terry was asking hey what could possibly
go wrong with a 27
600 square foot video screen on the side
of a legion stadium for folks to watch
football while they're driving by on the
freeway here's some responses like
gloria saying hey distracting drivers
with giant screens is stupid stupid
stupid
and she says isn't it bad enough they
refuse to put down their phones amen
gloria
from julie it's ridiculous to distract
drivers more than they already are
navigation screens phones in one hand
burgers in the other we're smarter than
that vegas save lives don't be foolish
enough to put big tvs next to our
roadways what's next roadside video
games you can hotspot into
keep those responses coming buckle up
drive carefully and please put down the
phone you can respond or if something's
driving you crazy the email address is
the same traffic eight at eight newsnow
dot com john heather an email with
stupid stupid stupidity i feel like i
got that yesterday from uh from someone
at the station you know it happens it
happens
good day that's a joke coming up on good
day las vegas
in uh new york getting ready for the
macy's thanksgiving day parade of course
as are we cuz you can watch it on tv
then new floats and balloons that'll
make their way through the big apple all
this piano music uh before we go to
break we thought you would gobble up
another live shot of
new york city perhaps as you're getting
ready here on a wednesday morning there
is beautiful manhattan on a wednesday
it's about 9 30 right now you're
watching good day las vegas thank you
for joining us
[Music]
only water one day a week from november
to february
right now on good day las vegas cracking
down on exotic car rentals what's behind
a majority of some of these wrecks and
what they have in common plus the
coronavirus vaccine deadline when mgm
resorts employees have to get their
shots or start paying for testing and
two decades of magic the cast of harry
potter celebrating the movies 20th
anniversary good day las vegas starts
right now
this is an 8 news now breaking news
alert
starting with a bit of breaking news
here the amber alert for a four-year-old
girl from nevada has now been canceled
elena dewey found safe in elko county
police though have issued an arrest
warrant for this woman 41-year-old
elizabeth croft investigators believe
that she kidnapped the girl
the girl the four-year-old is safe
good news all right at 6 30 here it is a
wednesday morning good morning you at
home heather good morning to you and
sheri good morning to you good morning
you guys happy wednesday everybody we've
had beautiful skies if you can see just
a hint of some clouds out there this
morning they've been passing through
really missing most of the valley and
just covering up the sun just ever so
slightly out there on the east side
temperatures have been cooling off to
the 50s and even some upper 40s as saint
rose parkway
has been in the upper 40s back to low
50s occasionally a little bit of a
breeze but mostly winds are calm around
the valley north las vegas been bumping
around a little bit with some northwest
breezes at times between 10-15 miles an
hour that's really where the winds
should stay today except along the river
i anticipate it's going to be stronger
winds for you laughlin bullhead city
maybe even all the way up to boulder
city today 63 back by midmorning we'll
see more high clouds i can see them on
the horizon already up to the northwest
side of northwest of clark county coming
our way 67 by noon and that right there
is already a click above the normal high
of 66 for today's date but we'll keep it
mostly sunny today yesterday we had
full-on sunshine for the afternoon with
highs in the mid 70s today a little bit
cooler eventually that front that's
right on top of us will slide on through
and that will cool us off a little bit
more for the week 6 30. let's get to the
drive with nate good morning nate good
morning sharon good morning to you
appreciate you getting your day started
with us here on good day las vegas
freeways not in bad shape you do have
the slowing you can see it here on our
freeway traffic map but actually in the
last couple of hours we had more crashes
right now we're crash free on our main
freeways there's somebody off on the
right shoulder heading out of town north
on the 95 or at the kyle canyon exit
they're on the right shoulder the big
slowdowns are going to be in the
spaghetti bowl with a big squeeze
earlier crash was southbound on the 95
515 around boulder highway you do have
the slowing on the northbound side
because that is generally the busier
flow of traffic as folks head into town
this is the southbound side here they've
got the restriction cones off on the
left after only two lanes during the
overnight hours there's one of the cars
left over from that earlier crash there
off on the right shoulder generally not
a bad drive we're keeping an eye on it
for you all morning long john 8 thank
you it is now 6 31. later this morning a
motion hearing scheduled on the deadly
crash involving former las vegas raider
henry ruggs he's accused of driving
drunk and causing that fiery crash which
killed 23-year-old tina tintor
ruggs is not expected to appear at the
hearing his actual next court appearance
scheduled for next month the q anon
shaman will learn his fate this morning
jacob chansley was among the group that
stormed the u.s capitol january 6. last
week the 33-year-old pleaded guilty to
obstructing an official proceeding
prosecutors have recommended a sentence
of a little more than four years which
would be the longest imposed on any
capital rioter so far
today is day two of jury deliberations
in the kyle rittenhouse trial in
wisconsin of this group of jurors they
did try to make a decision for more than
eight hours yesterday rittenhouse faces
charges following a shooting during a
black lives matter rally last year
investigators say he shot three people
two of them died his attorneys say it
was in self-defense
ladies and gentlemen
other people in this community have shot
somebody seven times and it's been found
to be okay
my client did it four times in three
quarters of a second to protect his life
if convicted rittenhouse could face life
in prison
now to our coverage of the coronavirus
covid19 cases are rising in more than 20
states however doctors might get some
new tools to help us fight the disease
pfizer's coronavirus vaccine booster
might be available for all adults here
in the u.s by the end of the week the
fda could authorize it as soon as
tomorrow and then approval from the cdc
could happen on friday
when we look back on this we will see
that boosters are likely a very critical
part of the immunization regimen 58
percent of all americans are fully
vaccinated against coronavirus on monday
the cdc reported more than 150 000 new
infections though for the first time in
two months
mgm resorts is requiring all employees
to be vaccinated against covet 19 by
monday workers who choose to skip the
vaccine now have to pay 38 dollars to
get a weekly test the testing has been
part of it for a while now mgm will
waive the fee though if employees start
the vaccine process by tuesday 90
employees quit the company after mgm's
previous vaccination deadline back in
october clark county commissioners are
looking to crack down on the exotic
rental car industry recent crashes
involving those exotic rentals are
prompting them to possibly implement a
new ordinance so the first step andrew
bennett from the nevada office of
traffic safety shared some data about
the industry and he says 95 percent of
those exotic rental crashes involve
impairment speed and impairment were
extremely prevalent in these luxury and
exotic rental
fatalities and so you know looking at
the possibilities of
ignition interlock is a program that
we've had in our state to reduce
impaired driving there is an opportunity
to do speed monitoring
next the county will take a look at some
of the data to see if they can implement
more regulation with a new ordinance 634
nevada's political maps are officially
redrawn for another decade at a special
session up in carson city the
democrat-led legislature approved a
redistricting plan the lines are changed
every 10 years following the census
three of nevada's four u.s house
districts are now majority minority
republicans complain though these new
districts are too favorable for
democrats and they are now expected to
file a lawsuit
all right so with online sales as we get
into the holiday season online sales
breaking records this year there's a new
study that predicts package thefts well
they're also going to rise those crimes
constant problem nationwide we talk
about them all the time maybe it's
happened to you there are some ways to
protect yourself hector mejia live this
morning and hector we learned that you
had your deodorant stolen so now you can
take these tips and help yourself it
smells horrible
that is true good morning guys and it's
never fun trying to figure out what
happened to your packages and we've
learned they're arriving early this year
with sales already underway you know all
of last year some 20 billion of these
packages were shipped all across the
country and a new study by cctv camera
world ranks nevada number 22 where you
are least likely to have a package
stolen they say you should still be
aware so they come through fbi crime
data for 2020 they pointed to a study
saying that 43 of those surveyed all
across the country reported having a
package stolen at least once that
actually went up from the year before
and almost two-thirds said it happened
to them more than once so this year
people are protecting their packages in
a number of ways you can sign up for
tracking and text alerts this feature
will notify you when your items arrive
you can also invest in what's being
called a porch lock box those are
designed with a code that you give to
the delivery service and then they lock
up your items when they arrive you can
also have your packages sent to work to
an amazon locker just choose in-store
pickup and of course you can also use
surveillance cameras and also consider
staying home if you can to make sure
you're there when your delivery arrives
reporting live this morning hector mejia
live local now okay good advice watch
for those boxes keep an eye out thanks
hector appreciate it